[Music]
it always feels like cheating to use a
clip from the view for the daily
cancellation but sometimes it's
unavoidable such as the case here where
a one minute exchange between the
squawking hens on the view serves as a
convenient rundown of all of the major
misnomers and false narratives that
we've been hearing over the past 24
hours
and uh this is the great and sacred
purpose of this show i think the public
service it provides it gives you a
condensed even more simplified summary
of every dumb thing the left is saying
about any given subject and that is
certainly the case here and i'll let
whoopi take it away listen
that's the question
what are we doing because we're we're
why are we always at square one with
this and i swear to god if i see another
republican senator talk about their
heart being broken i'm gonna go punch
somebody and kind of thoughts i can't
take it in their thoughts and prayers if
your thoughts and prayers were really
with everybody you'd have done something
by now
it's not like anybody's not trying to
make this happen what the hell is going
on
i want them to stop gaslighting me also
stop saying it's not it's not guns that
kill people it's people that kill people
it's guns they kill people okay stop
saying the opposite stop saying that
mental illness is behind this there's
mental illness in every country in the
world and they don't have this problem
so stop gaslighting me on that one and
stop saying that you can have a good guy
stop a bad guy with a gun we have seen
in both of these shootings in the past
three weeks that a good guy tried and
could not do it so stop gaslighting us
that about sums it up again everything
you heard there is standard leftist
boilerplate we hear all this after every
mass shooting and we've heard it all
incessantly since the shooting in texas
so let's go through it first we get the
complaints about thoughts and prayers
you know forget about your thoughts and
prayers they say we need to do something
but if you're religious as at least a
few of those women on the view claim to
be and as many of the people who
complain about thoughts and prayers
claim to be
then you should know that praying is
doing something it shouldn't be the only
thing you do you should do other things
along with praying but praying is
something
and the good thing is that nobody's ever
argued that all we should do is pray but
in the immediate moments after a
travesty like this
unless you're physically on the scene
and actively involved in that way there
may be nothing else you can do in that
moment at that exact time
but pray
okay like in the in the five minutes
after you hear about something like this
then it happened a thousand miles away
it's i want to do something well
in that exact moment
for most people there's probably like
almost nothing you could do in those
five minutes but you can pray
and why shouldn't you it's a good thing
this is not an either or choice it's not
mutually exclusive praying doesn't
prevent you from taking physical action
so what exactly is the complaint here do
we really think that the problem in our
society is that we're praying too much
is that the source of our troubles
really
as for doing something what do you want
to do
now the just do something mentality is a
scourge on our nation and on our body
politic
no we do not want our lawmakers simply
doing things
they already do a lot of things contrary
to popular beliefs they're not doing
nothing they're doing a lot of things
it's just that most of what they do is
ineffectual wasteful and often actively
harmful and counterproductive there's
nothing wrong with offering your prayers
after a mass shooting there is something
wrong with shouting into the void
somebody do something
that's a phrase that i would really like
to stop hearing
no problem is solved by doing something
problems are solved by doing particular
things
okay
it's it's like if you have a flat tire
you're not going to solve it just by
doing something there's a that's a a
particular problem very small problem
and it'll be solved in a certain
particular way
and that's true of every little small
problem you encounter in your life
you don't solve it just by just by
randomly taking action
you solve it by in targeted with
targeted action
and that's also true of the very big
problems in our society
and the reality is that the particular
things the gun control proponents want
to do
if you can even get them to propose any
particular things will not actually
prevent mass shootings and have not
prevented them as we discussed yesterday
a lot of these somethings have already
been put in place in many states and
cities across america and yet shootings
still occur and occur quite often
next we hear that it's not people who
kill people but guns and this is false
of course the inverse cliche doesn't
really work either in truth it's people
with guns who kill people but it's also
people without guns who kill people
people without guns kill people people
with guns kill people the common
denominator here is what
people
human choices human behavior kills
people
and so as we've been harping on we have
to get to the bottom of the human
behavior if we really want to make a
dent in this problem and finally and
here's the talking point i want to spend
some time with
we hear that this doesn't happen in
other countries
and i've heard this over and over and
over again since tuesday uh this doesn't
have another country as i said we're the
only country this sort of thing happens
what sort of thing and i suppose they
mean mass casualty attacks in fact the
onion on wednesday changed their home
page so that every headline on the whole
site says no way to prevent this says
only nation where this regularly happens
this is a very common claim the united
states is unique across the entire world
in this respect the left says are they
rights
no of course they aren't i mean not even
a little bit okay it's not even a little
right
in fact just south of the border this
week
uh a guy in mexico shot up a whole a
hotel killing 11 people
that was this week okay this week
and yet we're told this only happens in
america
that's not even true this week
in fact mass casualty attacks happen all
the time in mexico and all across
central and south america they happen
quite famously in the middle east and
all over africa many parts of asia
indeed to make the claim that we're the
only country where this kind of thing
happens you must disregard from the
outset the vast majority of the globe
and the vast majority of the people
living on it
that seems like a rather important
qualifier that the person claiming we're
the only place where this happens should
mention they should stipulate by that by
when they say only place
when they
they mean the only place if you don't
count almost the entire world
of course the mass shootings in a place
like mexico mexico are often different
than they are here uh in the sense that
they're well they're the same in that
the victims
but there still are victims who are
being killed
but the attacks in mexico are almost
always cartel related
if you go to somewhere like east africa
the terrorist group al-shabab is usually
responsible in other parts of the world
it's a different paracel or a different
crime network
and that's because young violent
hopeless nihilistic men in mexico are
likely to end up working for cartels in
east africa they're gonna find they're
gonna find uh al-shabaab as their elder
in america
they either end up joining street gangs
or they stay isolated in their mom's
basement until one day they explode
different manifestations but a similar
phenomenon this is the reason
by the way why rankings of school
shootings are irrelevant you've perhaps
seen that wikipedia list floating around
showing that america has hundreds of
school shootings while afghanistan has
had only three what they neglect to
mention is afghanistan also only has
like three people in school
there are lots of murders
lots of mass slaughter happening in that
country and in many of these other
countries that have very few school
shootings it just doesn't happen at
school very often
because school isn't a big part of their
culture
as we said different manifestations but
still the same sort of thing the same
sort of terrible thing
now i made this point on twitter
yesterday and i was immediately informed
that my argument isn't valid because
when people say
that we're the only place in the world
where this happens they really of course
just mean among western countries
that's a bit awkward isn't it
so what you're saying is that only the
predominantly white countries count
is that so when you say the entire world
you're actually just talking about the
white world
now i i don't agree with you that only
the white countries count only the
predominantly white countries count
but but let's just pretend that i do is
it true that we're the only country in
the western world where this happens
no in fact a ranking of annual death
rate per million from mass shootings in
north america and europe according to
world population review puts us at
number
behind czech republic belgium finland
switzerland slovakia albania macedonia
france serbia norway
now you could point out that norway
makes the list in fact it tops the list
largely because of one major attack back
in 2011. that's true
but that's what happens when you measure
this on a per capita basis which you
have to because norway has 5 million
people and we have 330 million people
so if you're gonna compare us in the
number of people that are killed in mass
shootings the only fair way to do it is
per capita
if you're measuring like the number of
people who do anything
we're going to beat norway on every
measure for everything because we have
so many more people than them
so when you measure it by per capita
basis the united states does not really
stand out
in fact john lott with the crime
prevention research center published a
report about two years ago on this
subject and here's what it says in the
abstract it says
the us is well below the world average
in terms of the number of mass public
shootings and the global increase over
time has become has been much bigger
than for the united states
over the 20 years from 1998 to 2017 our
list contains 272 attacks and at least 5
764 shooters outside the united states
and 62 attacks and 66 years within our
country why our count the u.s makes up
less than one point uh 13 percent of the
mass public shooters 1.77 of their
murders and 2.19 of their attacks all
these are much less than the us's 4.6
share of the world population attacks in
the us are not only less frequent than
other countries they are also much less
deadly on average out of the 101
countries where we have identified mass
public shootings occurring the united
states ranked 66th 66th in the per
capita frequency of these attacks
and 56 in murder rate not only have
these attacks been much more common
outside the u.s the us's share of these
attacks has declined over time
and this is all the case
even though the us is unique in having
such a large and demographically mixed
population so what does this prove that
we don't have a problem
that we should do nothing to protect our
kids in school
obviously not
all it proves is that the narrative from
the left is false
and the fact that it's false is
important
because the truth is important
so when they say we're the only country
where this happens that is not true on
any level by any measure no matter how
you're looking at it
and you cannot solve a problem by
misrepresenting
[Music]
but of course they're not trying to
solve the problem they're trying to
exploit it
that's an entirely different thing from
solving it
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated